did you ever imagine oil from a hundred
240 or two somewhere in the vicinity
cells well I think it's very hard to
predict commodity prices and if you look
at the history of oil prices they're
just these incredible fluctuations and
it and it happened so sure I mean it's
possible it'd probably be over a hundred
again someday but we might be over 100
one in five well talk well we might be
over onda we'll talk about international
relations and oil in China in emerging
markets in this hour but what does this
cheaper oil price mean for America it's
got to be a plus plus plus right okay
it's a plus plus minus because we're a
big producer shale with certainly you
know part of our story it's better for
Europe and Japan but it's good for the
United Howard what does it mean for your
equity portfolio do you load the boat on
the quality names like x hunter and a
darker you under the oil desk right now
hiding well I would certainly if I
didn't have any oil exposure i would use
this weakness to accumulate some and i
would probably recommend EOG resources
as my go-to name and energy patch as ken
said predicting the price of oil is very
difficult and unfortunately or
fortunately energy stocks tend to be
highly correlated to the price of crude
so you are making a bet on the price of
oil when that happens with all due
respect to Goldman Sachs is called for
twenty dollar oil when oil was it eighty
and ninety dollars I don't think they
thought it was going to go to forty
dollars so given the unpredictability of
oil given the supply response to what's
happening it's been slower than we would
have expected but I would certainly
venture to estimate that over the next
12 months we'll be looking at a higher
price of oil you have to materially hi
David what's important here whether it's
ed Morse at Citigroup or jeff korea
goldman sachs and the others is they
have a vision out two three and five
years they're not worried about where
it's going to be in three weeks know
exactly and then you have other
investors like Warren Buffett or
thinking about it in 5 10 50 years right
who amber Tate and they just invested in
phillips 66 downstream right so it saw
an opportunity there right of course
that is a little bit different because
actually they benefit from lower prices
because of the spread they get on
refining but look when prices are down
you want to buy and you know
unfortunately the price of crude fell so
quickly
down fifty percent still from the jun
2014 peak we're all condition right to
associate that with some sort of doom
ken rogoff you have been out front with
Carmen ride hard about saying don't just
look at visible debt there is private
economy debt as well part of the heart
of your research including or acclaimed
book this time is different is Brazil
exposed to the private debt you worry
about in your book well it has a lot of
corporate dollar debt and when the
exchange rate you know tanks by 10 sixty
percent or something then obviously
that's problematic so that's certainly
one of the elements going on in Brazil
the government debt you know it's not so
worrisome but there's certainly a lot of
corporate debt and private debts grown I
mean it's not at the levels we see in
advanced countries but sure but it's
it's one of many problems in Brazil it's
eames to me Brazil's one thing that's
many of us in the really not paid enough
attention to it's a large economy it's
very second largest in the Western
Hemisphere right it's ten times the size
of Greece there with all the attention
we spent degrees and and they're looking
at some pretty lean times it looks like
for some time don't you think they are I
mean it's a combination of two things
when the leading thing is the global
commodity prices have fallen and they
were sort of riding off you know
drafting off China but unfortunately you
know Dilma Rousseff has followed a lot
of interventionist very
counterproductive policies didn't matter
so much when the economy was growing
anyway and now you know there's nothing
to fall back on and they're having also
trouble with their fiscal policy their
monetary policy because they weren't
more careful in the good times but rusev
as I understand had pursued really a
populist sort of policy oh absolutely
going that was her base as it were
politically but now she's sort of in a
jam because she's going to have limited
resources to be able to appeal to those
masses isn't she that should double down
on that play I mean lavie the for the
finance minister wanted to go the other
way with more of an austerity program
but is he going to be able to do that
well I mean he they're not sustainable
they've been downgraded to junk there's
something needs to happen he was brought
in it was either a brave of them to come
in
and there isn't really the political
support to do anything whether we hit a
good job in the private sector you
didn't have to take this job it's a fair
now he is a very brave man and so yeah
it's very tough and the central bank at
the same time they haven't really
reformed it enough and so it's on
somebody and results that it's like
Arthur burns trying to be vulgar after
inflating all this look I'm going to
change and not in flight anymore very
quickly hard Ward is it with investor
has to be opportunity are you when do
you go in and overweight large-cap
international stocks or emerging market
stocks Azhar a trigger that you look for
it gamco well you know again market
timing is very perilous just like timing
commodity prices timing the stock market
is pretty hard to do and few people do
but elton would say shares are on sale
well i don't know if they're on sale rap
i think very defensible I you know we've
had a correction we had the full ten
percent plus correction I think we're
doing maybe eight percent now that was
overdue and a lot of stocks are down
twenty percent some more the multiple
and extras earnings is 15 you have an
economy with about three percent growth
to % rates I can't believe its stock
market stays down for very long or goes
very much lower so yes i would be a
buyer and you want to go where the fear
is the greatest and right now that would
be in the companies that have that
international exposure we're thrilled to
have you with us i had four out of seven
children call in the last 48 hours their
iphones have broken did you know that it
has to do with apple and she's your
fault well i'll tell you tom i set my
alarm for five o'clock this morning on
my iphone and it didn't go upward over
sleeping on the way to bloomberg
surveillance and Ken Rogoff with us as
well of Harvard that universes